for a battle that takes place 365 days a
year we know that the world aids day is
really just a symbol an opportunity not
only to raise awareness of the ongoing
global challenge but to raise our sights
and to take stock of our collective work
in combating hiv/aids for those around
the world and here at Columbia who are
working on the front lines today is also
a chance together and to reflect both on
what works and on what doesn't work also
to assess the long path ahead this year
world's AIDS Day theme is universal
access and human rights so it's fitting
that this symposium on HIV scale up in
global health systems is co-hosted here
at Columbia by two organizations that
have admired leaders in bridging the
treatment gap both the William J Clinton
Foundation and Columbia's international
center for AIDS care and treatment
programs or icap have demonstrated
transformative leadership in expanding
access to prevention and treatment of
HIV AIDS since 2004 I cap has supported
hiv/aids prevention care and treatment
programs and related activities in 13
African countries it was a great
privilege of mine my wife Jane to visit
several of them at the very start of
this a few years ago focused on
strengthening health systems through
comprehensive programs that address
hiv/aids as well as related health
issues icap uses a family-centered
approach focusing on service programs
training research monitoring and
evaluation
as well as education it is a proven
model of effectiveness even in areas of
limited resources and challenging
conditions I cap has provided more than
750,000 people access to HIV care and
358 thousand individuals with HIV
treatment and has indirectly benefited
millions more I cap is one of the many
initiatives at the mailman School of
Public Health led by our new wonderful
Dean Linda freed and indeed throughout
Columbia University making great strides
forward in the fight against hiv/aids
from northern Manhattan to South Asia
across the university the crisis of
hiv/aids is addressed of programs
working in a range of disciplines and
focusing at both global and local levels
for example our School of Social Work
the social intervention group is working
with the University of Malaya to
identify forces that fuel hiv/aids the
epidemic among commercial fishermen from
Malaysia and neighboring countries
Columbia addresses the epidemic in our
own community as well through the HIV
center for clinical and behavioral
studies an organization created in
partnership with the new york state
psychiatric institute through this
initiative we conduct interdisciplinary
research on hiv/aids related issues and
offer outreach and support to HIV
infected and affected populations in New
York City these are just a few of the
many ongoing initiatives across Columbia
schools and institutes we are deeply
grateful also to President Clinton and
the William J Clinton Foundation for
co-hosting this event President Clinton
has been an extraordinarily important
leader in combating the hiv/aids crisis
it is worth noting that in 1995 it was
President Clinton who made the first
official proclamation of World AIDS Day
setting a precedent that prompted other
world leaders to follow suit and since
President Clinton has left office the
William J Clinton Foundation's work has
made huge strides in closing the gap in
access to HIV AIDS care in 2002
President Clinton's HIV aids initiative
was established working both with drug
manufacturers the lower prices for
antiretroviral treatment and with local
governments to improve healthcare
systems and to deliver medicines I'm
also glad to say that despite his
extraordinary global schedule President
Clinton has found time for several
visits to our campus we are very pleased
with our collaborations we are sustained
by his being in the neighborhood on one
hundred and twenty fifth Street and we
are also deeply proud of the fact that
he is friend and apparent the work of
organizations like the William J Clinton
and foundation and I cap have had both
tangible consequences on the lives of
those affected by aids while also paving
the way towards improving access to
critical hiv/aids care recent figures
from the CDC note that at the end of
2008 an estimated four million persons
in low and middle income countries were
receiving therapy representing an
increase of thirty six percent over the
previous year so we're very proud the
mailmen schools I cap in the program and
the Clinton Foundation have helped bring
us together today to discuss the global
and domestic state of AIDS let me also
say that just as we're in a world in
which the financial or the media
industry is experiencing a constriction
in coverage of foreign news it's all the
more important that we have events like
this to help
understand what's going on so now I'd
like to introduce the panelists of
course President Clinton founder of the
William J Clinton Foundation dr. wafaa
al-sadr director international center
for aids care and treatment programs
also a MacArthur Fellow see Virginia
fields president and CEO of the national
black leadership Commission on AIDS
kaylee Lindsay senior director for
federal policy Harlem United Community
aids Center and dr. Stephen Lewis
co-director of the aids-free world were
very pleased and proud to have all of
these distinguished individuals here
today
all of us having been introduced will
start immediately and I will direct the
first reflective question to the
president which is I think both an
obvious question but an important one
which is quite simply why hold an event
of this kind on world aids day at this
moment it is the question though I am
honored to answer it and let me begin by
thanking dr. Bowen through president
Bulger and Dean free for having us back
at Columbia and I want to thank our
panelists I think we should do it for
two reasons because number one Americans
have tended to grow complacent about the
challenges in America and about what it
would take for us to adequately meet
them in number two Americans I think
tend to assume that because of the
dramatic increase in activity in the
rest of the world because of the Global
Fund because of the PEPFAR program that
President Bush initiated because of the
work of the Gates Foundation and the
work that our foundations do and others
that we're on the way to a complete
resolution of this globally and I don't
think either one of those things is true
so I wanted to do that and in America we
have discrete populations of Americans
where the eight infection rate is going
up we still don't have everyone on
treatment we still haven't done as much
as we could do on testing and prevention
and other things and in the world I
think we can say with some conviction
that no one will die of AIDS this year
because the drugs are too expensive or
in short supply but a lot of people are
going to die of AIDS and malaria and
tuberculosis
in coincident cases because of the
absence of health care systems out there
to do the testing do the education to do
the prevention work to distribute some
medicine to do the follow-up and that's
what I hope will talk about today why we
still need a world aids day and I'll
just give you one example we had a
million people at it in the treatment
rose now we have more than four million
people in poor countries throughout the
world on treatment half of them on
contracts our foundation negotiated
including we have more than 200,000
children on pediatric medicine which is
more than sixty percent of all the kids
in the world but it's a tiny fraction of
the children who need it and it's still
only barely over forty percent of those
in the world who need the medicine to
stay alive the rest of them are not
getting their medicine primarily because
there are no delivery systems out there
so we need to talk about that and we
need to talk about how we've kind of let
our attention slip here at home thank
you sir wafaa you've dealt so widely
internationally yesterday wh 0 changed
the guidelines on the initiation of
treatment to begin it rather earlier
which means I think objectively that
they're probably something in the
vicinity of over 10 million people who
require treatment now according to their
guidelines with only four million
receiving it there is tremendous anxiety
in this country over what is described
as the flat lining of the budget of the
administration's budget and the seeming
pullback in providing the resources that
are necessary to both sustained and
increase the treatment as a matter of
fact if this isn't presumptuous or
untoward a group of quite thoughtful
activists NGOs yesterday gave President
Obama a d-plus she's unusual mark in
this administration's history for for
the response to AIDS and there is a
there is a very strong feeling that the
slowing down in funding is going to
compromise people's lives can you
comment on all
thank you very much Steven I think if we
step back and think about how we got to
where we got it was through tremendous
mobilization and clearly groups like Tom
have worked on this for years and years
including the president and the Clinton
Foundation I cap and many others have
tried to mobilize the resources to make
a difference and it really is tragic to
reach a point down where we can reach we
can make a difference we're starting to
see improvement in life's in life
expectancy in countries like Botswana
decrease in mortality in countries like
South Africa that we would be would not
be able to to reach the finish line
essentially and to really vanquish HIV
both in terms of treatment and
prevention in reality even without the
change in the guidelines there'll be a
chore guidelines even without changing
the gardens we still about half
two-thirds of people who still need
treatment today so I think the bar is
much higher and it is considered a
difficult time and difficult economic
time at a time when people are making
choices between the domestic epidemic
the global epidemic the other health
threats that are facing the world and in
a way it's a moment where we stepping
back and we've been discussing today
this morning at a full day symposium how
HIV can catalyze the transformation of
health systems how can we use the
resources better how can we build on the
foundation of what PEPFAR has
established what other people have
funded and established how can we build
on that so that we can actually
capitalize on the hound
to be able to reach to do much more
nonetheless without advocacy and that
commitment of new funding unfortunately
that the people were not going to get
treatment and unfortunately women who
will not be treated and the be children
who are not going to be treated so on
world aids day we come together to
reenter her energize all of us and on
the cause and the cause of maintaining
sustaining the commitment the global
commitment to HIV the global commitment
to the health of poor people around the
world and the global commitment to
transforming the health systems around
the world to systems there are humane
appropriate high quality and effective
wafaa do you buy the argument which is
more and more stated that too much money
has gone to AIDS at the expense of other
areas of health particularly maternal
and child health and that there should
be an extraction of some of the AIDS
money for the other alternatives given
the financial crisis unfortunately I
find that that argument is not useful
it's often divisive and it and takes
people who should be working on the same
side they put some into as enemies
across the air across that I'm rather
than together and I think the pine has
to grow bigger the commitment to health
is very vital to commitment to
development and again synergizing
between HIV child health maternal health
together in the context of strengthening
health systems can actually get us all
to achieve what we want so I I think
again it is not a useful argument take
away from HIV and put into something
else I think there are more potential
for synergies and complementary zand
growing together and solving problems
together rather than hitting people who
should be really battling the same
battle together may I say to call the
panelists that if they want to jump in
on any discussion please do so and I saw
you smiling and thoughtful
to yourself Virginia did you want to
comment no I just simply was agreeing
with the last comment that it really
becomes very divisive when we talk about
whether or not one approach or one
disease should be considered over
another or if money should go in one
area reality is we must remain focused
as the doctors said on all of this so
that was the point of agreement for real
well let me take you further into the
domestic domestic scene which is clearly
important in this discussion and I will
admit to being an appalling ignoramus in
the context of exactly what is happening
in the United States but but I get the
sense given that there were fifty three
thousand additional more than 53,000 new
infections last year and such a
disproportionate number within the
african-american community and
particularly amongst women and the
situation we've now learned as extent in
Washington can you make comment on all
of that from your policy viewpoint that
you that you pursued oh I think it is
true that last year when the Center for
Disease Control released its report it
showed that there were far more new
incidence of HIV than initially thought
56 thousand three hundred among that
population we saw a disproportionate
amount among people of color
african-americans african-american black
gay men MSM men who have sex with men
and black women and I think that what it
has shown is that we must make sure that
we know exactly where the resources are
going and that the resources are going
into the areas of greatest need and
preliminary work that has been done by
the National black leadership Commission
on AIDS of where I sit as the president
and CEO we're finding that that is not
the case and the disproportionate
numbers that we r sin among black women
but when we think historically women of
color and children have been heavily
impacted
by aids HIV since its inception and
black women showed unusual signs of age
very early on but they were misdiagnosed
or classified as prostitutes or not
diagnosed at all and now only since 1992
when the Center for Disease Control
expanded its definition to include not
only tuberculosis pneumonia but stage
three of cervical cancer that we begin
to see major changes for women living
with AIDS so I'm sure that those numbers
are also a part of what we're seeing now
today and as we look today there are
many issues that are impacting why
perhaps we're seeing this
disproportionate amount among especially
black women it goes to traditional
relationship structures which I'm sure
many in the audience can agree with and
know about negotiating the use of
condoms you know these men will tell you
things baby I'm okay you know you can
trust me and it's not always the case
we've got to push for a safer sex use of
condoms getting people to test it no one
our partners reducing the number of
partners all of those things are a part
of I think where we need to be going
today so that we can reduce the
disproportionate impact within the
african-american community generally and
black women specifically kalid you want
to enter into this discussion yes you
know it's interesting that we're talking
about you know how we've grown since the
beginning of the epidemic since 1992 I
think we've seen is that we've done a
lot of work to expand access to HIV
testing technologies like access to
medications were a great amount of
people within the country but knowing
and understanding that there are still
far too many individuals I don't have
access to healthcare for the longest
period of time I've been fighting for
early X
to treatment for people with HIV before
they progress to an AIDS diagnosis still
in 2009 you have to have AIDS before you
qualify for health care through Medicaid
even more astonishing to me is that over
seventy percent of the individuals that
are acquiring HIV in the United States
are bisexual men we don't even have a
way to access or provide information to
a more comprehensive sexuality education
and our schools doesn't speak to them it
doesn't provide them with the
information that they need to protect
themselves to protect their families and
communities how can we really get
control of the epidemic if we're not
speaking in a language to the people
that we need to talk to the most and
then when we talk about access to
resources where can we find affordable
clinic is where can we apply an
affordable health care where can we find
quality food and nutrition and the areas
that are most hardest hit by HIV events
in the poorest neighborhoods in the
Harlin's in the Detroits in the areas of
our country that are the most arrest
native I poverty how to really speak to
them and start to give them empowerment
so that they can be able to control
their own lives and control their
susceptibility of vulnerability to HIV
thank you you know it it occurs to me
that we're beginning to respond to the
issues of sexual minorities
internationally although very
incrementally and in some ways there are
steps back when legislation is very
punitive particularly anti-gay
legislation but around women we've seen
in many ways to be stalled the
disproportionate numbers of women which
is obviously a reality domestically as
well as internationally the world cannot
adequately respond whatever it is that
yields paralysis the world around women
the gender inequality is so deeply
entrenched we're just not making the
kind of progress we have to make rest'
ill at 60 61 percent of all of the of
the population that's infected in Africa
23 million people 60 61 percent are
women and much higher percentages
between the 15 and 24 year old age
groups so where do we go around this
particular issue which is so vexing and
so appalling I like to say that I think
a couple of things we
look to do first let's begin with the
message we need to have messages that
relate to women across the board I think
there are still certain lot of
misperception that only a certain level
of women or become an infected
low-income women or women who are in the
streets or women who are engaged in drug
use we need a message that speaks to all
women that this is a disease that
affects potentially can affect all women
so that message must be directed to
women of all ages economic groups
geographical locations and as I talk for
example and my organization will
recognize this one of the women's
organizations of which I'm a member of
the links service organization phenomena
if they had a convention about a year
last year and for the first time they
had a session on AIDS and the title was
what does that capital tht have to do
with me and once we began to talk about
it the transmission of this disease and
how it affects all women that turned
around that conversation to encourage
many of those saying women to be active
at the local level making sure that they
get tested they become more educated and
to get involved so I think the message
is important and the messenger is also
as is important we need to make sure
that we're involved in women who are
living with AIDS to be talking about
these issues to be at the tables making
the decisions about budgets about
policies of our programs and services
and that they are not sitting on the
sidelines when these kind of decisions
are being made and I think at least
addressing the issues some from that
perspective will lead us in a direction
that I believe is certainly needed
this time offer I agree completely with
my colleague I think the issue is one
needs to always reflect on what is the
cause of that vulnerability of women in
our midst in the US and globally and
it's very complex it has to do with
vulnerability of women in general not
just to each IV there are lots of
structural issues about poverty social
issues empowerment issues control of the
economy education access to a lot of
opportunities within societies and I
think in a way when one has to think of
the vulnerability of women in the
context of the societies in which they
exist unfortunately societies often have
not transformed themselves into
equitable societies that really care
about the women in a matter that can
protect them I and in a way our
interventions have been maybe too
narrowly focused we thought we thought
about the vulnerability in terms of
sexual exposure and protection from a
specific partner rather than thinking of
our interventions much more broadly
based of really broad interventions more
of structural interventions that are
necessary in this country for example
issues about you know in many rural
areas in the south where many of the men
are in prisons the rates of
imprisonments in our country is
remarkable especially amongst African
American men the issues about the
educational system disenfranchised
education of teenagers and schools and
the quality of school all of these set
vulnerabilities into motion and I think
we need to reflect and think much more
broad based on how to protect women I
also think we can't focus on women alone
yet because I'm the role of men men are
very important and when we're focusing
on durability of women one also needs to
bring the issues of boys and men and
keep them front and central I think
I was just talking about a program that
we're trying to envision that I'm
calling men matter men do matter when
you're trying to work with women in the
fear when you're trying to protect women
it's very critical that boys are raised
in a society that enables respect across
this between boys and girls and
therefore respective in men and women
and that there can be then the potential
for generation of relationships of
equity and I think it's through these
generations that hopefully will see a
society where there's no violence
there's no sexual violence against women
there's no exploitation of women there's
protection of women as well as also
creating the much more of a harmonious
societies and harmonious communities
around the world wafaa those are
generational things they take a lot of
time and the women are being infected
now and are are in such a compromised
position now what do you do about
internationally well what do you do
about the significant transmission of
the virus through sexual violence
whether it's the politically
orchestrated sexual violence of his in
Bob way or the post-election violence
and the Kenya or the terrifying violence
of a Congo or a Darfur or indeed the
kinds of studies that have just been
done in Swaziland would show that young
girls have been subject to an incredible
degree of sexual violence within the
home they fought before they did the
study and it was a CDC study that it
would be in the schools it turns out to
be in the homes with with intimate
partners and relatives how do you how do
you deal with those things well for how
do we dress them very tough question and
but we have to address them today
I think again we need to approach it at
multi levels I think we have to have the
laws that protect women the laws that
punish the perpetrators of violence
whatever that may be that's very
important and then not only have the
laws but also respect those laws and
take them to action so that people feel
that they're going to be responsible for
their actions and then we need to work
with the women themselves empower them
to speak up that this is not the norm
this is not what should happen that this
is actually aberrant behavior that
should be stopped and to enable them
through working we do it through working
of women's groups for example women come
together and one woman is able to speak
up and she creates that environment or
other women can speak up and lo and
behold you have a group of women who are
speaking up and saying no and I think
it's an incremental process that can
would take will not happen overnight but
I think it has to be at multi levels at
all levels of society so that we can be
working at all these lleva so we can
change and transform and protect these
women in this very horrific from these
very horrific events mr. president
you've been so deeply involved in all of
this as you've traveled did you make
remarks on this well first I think I
think it's important to have the
individual role models who are respected
and speak out and I agree with what
Virginia said limited in listed two and
several other countries where we work
the most effective people are young
people who are hiv-positive who talked
about it and refused to be victims keep
in mind a lot of the developing
countries there's still a lot of stigma
attached to it and there's still a lot
of fear and just having people say okay
here are the facts I was raped and I'm
I've got AIDS and medicines keeping me
alive and I refuse to be a victim is
incredibly liberating to women who hear
that young women same things true for
young men i mean i wish that today on
world aids day we had that if I thought
of this I wish we had
a hundred thousand personal stories on
Facebook and YouTube and all these
websites you know just people at and and
also with men saying I'm I've got AIDS
and its really wrong for me to destroy
women's lives or other men's lives and
not behave responsibly just we just need
to flood this out there and in the
developing world it's highly empowering
to have individuals then I think getting
these groups are important i remember
when i was president I went to Africa in
my second term and Hillary had been
working on this whole issue of female
genital mutilation and she started by
getting women's groups and then there
was always every time there was a
woman's work there was an auxiliary
group of men who supported them and
pretty soon just because somebody like
us showed up and blessed them and they
got publicity they couldn't be punished
any more they couldn't be isolated
anymore they couldn't be marginalized
anymore I think a lot of this stuff
happens not according to some real
script but almost organically it comes
up if you can start it in the right
direction and the changing the culture
is really hard and I confess you know
mostly we focus on just getting out
there and testing people and getting
them to medicine them and they need it
and getting the children the nutritional
support and all we ought to talk about
that in a minute both in America and
elsewhere but I've seen this make a
difference and I think it's only thing
that will make a difference because we
all know that people are most at risk of
communicating the virus shortly after
they get it when they're least likely to
have been tested and found positive so
this is really important that we do this
agreed Kelly I think you wanted to enter
this fray yeah I think it would be
wonderful if we got to the point where
we have a hundred thousand stories on
facebook but we all know that
the reasonable barrier just having a
hundred thousand personal stories on
Facebook is the stigma that's attached
to that as president thing was just
talking about you know for myself I also
know that as soon as I you know tell
people that I'm a person living with
eight at the age of 29 who found out
that he had AIDS at the age of 23 after
being diagnosed with aids in an
emergency room hospital with 104-degree
temperature I was losing my life that
there will be a lot less invitations to
birthday parties and social events after
this because there is still a stigma
attached nobody wants to necessarily be
associated with an individual or with
the AIDS virus and we have to do
something about creating realistic and
honest conversations in our country to
able to be able to do something about
the epidemic we have to talk about
sexuality we have to talk about economic
in structural barriers we have to talk
about the quality of education and
what's going on in our communities and
societies because only when were able to
have those conversations and we were
able to really respond to what's going
on on the streets of our communities and
we correspond from love you know with
all due respect to President Clinton I
think one of the things that we saw
during the recent election was just
amount of celebration around the world
from a tenor and a message that talked
about things that we can do instead of
things that we can't do and I think we
need to find every opportunity to talk
to people about how we can expand what
were able to do in this country how
America can again act as a leader and
the fight against aids instead of
following you know in other individuals
footsteps how can we step out in the
forefront and teach the world how to
take control of AIDS and truly eradicate
it from our communities go ahead
Virginia and to add to what college is
said with respect to stigma there's also
a system complacency and we find this to
be a tremendous barrier as we work
throughout this country in the 12 or
more cities where the national black
leadership Commission of age now have
its affiliates this is just so
complacency that hiv/aids no longer
problem part of it is what people see on
the television
they see on the billboards if this
person is living with it they're okay
and all I have to do is take my
medication not understanding again as we
know there is no cure for HIV so the
sense of complacency seems to be
allowing or people are more comfortable
with having unprotected sex and risk in
other ways of contracting the disease
then perhaps they should be so we've got
a breakthrough that also people don't
believe for example I was doing a radio
show earlier this morning on wwl and
every time I talk about the nine point
five minutes at CDC States and the
person will become infected with age and
as I was looking at my watch I think
I've been here at Columbia University
for about 90 minutes so that's probably
about what about 10 or nine more new
persons who become infected since we
have been in this place today people
don't believe the numbers the numbers
are staggering so we must do more to
talk about it we must keep it in the
forefront we must do more of getting
comprehensive sex education in our
public schools as we are seeing the
increase of sexually transmitted
infections among younger people we must
talk about sex and I think the the role
of a black clergy is a plan in all of
this is really making a difference in
many of the cities where we are working
one of the things which is true of the
United States is that and my country of
Canada is that there are very very few
children who are ever infected but in
the world at large the reality of the
need to treat children and the hundreds
of thousands of children who are born
hiv-positive still every year we haven't
really talked about children and one of
the things that the mailman school did
Wafaa I remember
that when when when Alan rosenfield was
was was Dean the emergence of the pmtct
plus the prevention of mother-to-child
transmission plus where the focus
shifted in significant measure to the
mother something that the world had paid
little attention to until that moment
wafaa were still seeing this terrible
number of kids infected year after year
when the intervention through drugs
should be pretty easy do you want to do
you want to discuss that we haven't
talked about children I think it's one
of the I mean they've been a lot of
advances over the past several years and
I think we need to really celebrate them
I think we can't forget how much
progress has happened but in the arena
of children with HIV we have always to
go and I think it requires and what
we've tried to do it i get busily
conceptualizing the whole concept of how
mother to child prevention of
mother-to-child transmission should be
done by thinking of the mother by
thinking of the family as the unit of
action and in shaping the interventions
and shaking the program so actually it
can be a family approach so that women
pregnant women can come into care into
any little care get the attention they
need get tested get the care they need
for their own health as well as to
enable protection of their children but
nonetheless I think in in many ways we
fail to make the connections that every
single woman every single pregnant woman
get that said every single pregnant
woman gets the care she needs and every
single pregnant woman you stick what
protects her child and her child needs
to get the access to the treatment that
they need and that's where I think we
need to continue to mobilize the
resources to be able to reach literally
millions of children at risk or infants
at risk without having this enormous
expansion of programs that are focused
around prevention or transmission I
think it has that in many ways
unfortunately the start of prevention of
mother-to-child transmission
as a little island by itself and we have
to bring it back into a holistic
approach of comprehensive care to
families with HIV and maybe if we put it
in the framework and bring it into the
mainstream of HIV programs we actually
might be more effective in reaching in
prevention new transmissions but also in
bringing children who are already
infected to get access to the treatment
thanks to the work of the president and
his foundation and providing access to
those treatments but I think that it's
going to require a concerted effort and
there lots of partnerships new
partnerships are happening around the
world to try to help them rican
sexualizing protection of children and
protection of families I I want to make
a quick confessional so I can sleep
tonight the the people with whom I work
do not use prevention of mother-to-child
transmission I'm using it because it's
an easy phrase we use vertical
transmission because we refuse to
demonize the mother nobody ever asks who
infected the mother so when you say
mother to child transmission you're
immediately demonizing women which is a
constant pattern in this world of which
we want no part but but the truth is
that the that the pediatric aids
dimension is something mr. president
that you've thrown the foundation into
which was terribly neglected before you
began to enter that arena and it would
remember seeing you in the suit oh when
you were dealing with kids and I may be
worth saying something about well let me
say first of all out on the prevention
of mother-to-child add the thing that I
have seen it if you have some sort of
basic network out there and you get the
word out mothers don't want their kids
to be born with HIV I mean they're very
responsible all you have to do is
empower them to take this medicine and i
will say it one of the things that I
think we have to do I agree with what
you said wafaa about not wanting to get
AIDS in a fight with somebody else for
limited dollars but one of the things
that we see is if you build elemental
healthcare networks in very poor area
where they don't exist everything gets
better you know that aids program gets
better than larrya tuberculosis maternal
and child health somehow somebody shows
up and some tropical diseases get
treated it didn't get treated I mean I
think this is an opportunity to overcome
the part of the problem that the
activists had with President Obama's
budget I think that for whatever it's
worth I personally strongly disagree
with the the condemnation because of if
you look at the circumstances that
they're facing with budget and the other
options we have to increase care
including taking the food security
budget and settings that some for
nutritional programs that specifically
target people with HIV and AIDS and
especially children and a lot of other
things that can be done I think we we
can do more with this budget that people
think and you got in Eric Goosby I think
you've got a guy running this PEPFAR
office he's really committed to doing
the right thing but anyway i think i
think that the mother to child
transmission every place where when our
hiv/aids people in the nielsen is here
today and maybe some other people from
their initiative they're really working
hard on this but what we find is if you
create an opportunity they do show up if
you say look this is a problem here you
just empower people they show up they
make good things happen it's okay test
me give me the medicine you know we
don't have when your children get
involved you don't have many of the
reservations that still obtain about the
stigma and the other things that you
previously thought at least that's our
experience so I know I sound like a
broken record but my honest belief is we
do have nutritional problems but to
medicine the medicine treatment for the
kids is about 60 bucks a year now the
mother to child transmission treatment
is that you all know it's not very
expensive that what we got to do is to
find an affordable and predictable
revenue stream that will allow the
building of these healthcare networks to
continue
I think in the developing world that's
the most important thing now here it's a
different story but there I believe we
can make breathtaking progress on mother
to child transmission if you have the
people out there in enough places with
and essentially you got the Global Fund
you've got all the PEPFAR to be fair as
increasingly spending some of its money
on health systems unit 8 which was set
up to buy diseases of the poor you know
funded primarily by the French airline
tax decided originally they were going
to be just a hundred percent in the
medicine business they give us a very
small percentage of the overhead to help
build out the networks to deliver the
goods but that's something I think we
should all be thinking about do we
really has our laudatory focus on
medicine our nutrition or anything else
undermined our awareness that there has
to be and we're not talking about
expensive systems here but just
elemental systems for medical
distribution checking on the adherence
that you know freezing the blood sample
are refrigerating the blood samples and
transporting them just stuff that
doesn't cost a lot of money but makes it
all the difference in life and death out
there that's what I think we should be
focusing on work in the developing world
well that's a good speech on man and I
appreciate it and I actually intend to
speak to her about it but what would you
do if you were the president you maybe
you'd say well he shouldn't spend any
money in Afghanistan but the we have
this a women wait wait wait I wouldn't
say that by the way I but I'm very
sympathetic with the problem he's in he
just spent 800 billion dollars and the
congressional budget office today said
it created between I think six hundred
thousand a million half jobs he's in a
terrible bind he has to get this money
from China they're trying to reform the
health care system I personally believe
that that you can't have universal
health insurance in a way that does not
benefit people with HIV and AIDS I think
we get universal health care out there
it will help a lot to fund the network
that we need that will improve care for
people with HIV and AIDS and I if and I
haven't talked to anybody I didn't know
anything about this I must tell you too
I respect your request I'm embarrassed
to tell you I didn't know what the
budget request was until I started doing
the preparation for world aids day so I
have no idea what the White House
response is but I know this they passed
that health care bill you're going to
get a lot more money spent on HIV and
AIDS and if we pass the food security
initiative we're going to have a lot
more nutrition aid for people with HIV
and AIDS around the world yes I will
speak to them but i want to tell you the
president's had a nightmare economic
situation and the Congress is coming
down on in day and night while he's
trying to get universal health care
which would help people with HIV and
AIDS and he's also cut back on some in
Hillary's development budget which I
didn't like either we all don't like it
you know but I've been there and somehow
he's got to deal with this I will speak
with them I think that they may think
the Americas done so much more everybody
else they can slow down a while I don't
agree with that but let's look and see
where there's other money that we might
yeah let's look and see whether what if
we shifted some money into the global
fund where every dollar we put up is
supposed to be matched by two dollars
from some from other sources are they
prepared to do that should we do more
multilaterally in this regard let's look
and see whether if the food security
initiative that the president has
basically charged Hillary with
developing and implementing if that how
much of that money could be used for
people with HIV and AIDS in the poor
countries I think you got a legitimate
point look the last thing we need to do
is back up we've only got we're only
treating forty-two percent of people who
need this medicine to stay alive and a
smaller percentage of the children and
every time I give a speech and I say
that our our partnership at unit eight
is treating two-thirds of all the poor
children in the world are getting
medicine and people clap I make them
stop because then I tell them what a
lousy percentage it is of the total
number of kids in need of medicine to
stay alive so I am extremely sympathetic
with what you said but I also have to
defend the miserable position the
president and his budget ears are in
under these circumstances and just
remember at least in America if we get
this health care thing it will improve
aids care it will if we change the
Medicaid guidelines to comport with the
testing recommendations which they can
probably do by executive action I bet
Kathleen Sebelius can do that on that
will make a huge difference there are
other things we can do and I promise you
now that I am aware of this I will do my
best to squeeze more blood out of the
turnip and I thank
oh I
III want personally to thank the
obstreperous intervention from I think a
health gap colleague because you're a
hell of a lot better than the moderator
you keeps us from being so boring to its
nose really good thank you any other any
other heckling spasms that you would
like to invoke please don't oh my god I
didn't I'm well well let's take a moment
and raised let's take a moment then and
raise the fact that we're now entering
into the concentrated epidemics of men
having sex with men sex workers and
injecting drug use and the harm
reduction programs and this fellow is
talking about needle exchange well i can
let me just say this first of all we
should also give the administration for
credit for changing this policy on
people with hiv/aids coming to America
I'm ashamed that it happened it was
present when I was there and I think
they're right and that's why we're going
to get the International AIDS meeting
here I changed my position on needle
exchange I think it's the right I think
it will save lives and i think the the
thing that one of the things that at
least we ought to do is maybe get that
as i remember the republican congress
went and the president went that then
president took away the local option
from the District of Columbia or try it
isn't that right and I think that at a
minimum since a lot of these problems
are highly concentrated in urban areas
if they don't want to fight this heat
now one of the things you might consider
doing that I would strongly support is
giving this decision back to the
community aids networks and the local
governments involved and because I think
there's no question what we do here in
Harlem there's no question what we do in
most of the New York City no question
what would happen in Washington DC where
we've got a terrible problem on our
hands and so I agree with you
I think this is a decision made by
people who live in the areas where it's
not a problem and people are queasy
about drug use that affect the lives of
people who live in areas where it is a
problem and if they don't want to come
out and flat-out endorse needle exchange
you ought to ask them to give it back
and have a local option and I think that
a lot of a lot of our communities our
pirate the Harlem AIDS clinic here i
think you know we could make a lot of
good happen out of that are I am I
anticipated that there might be others
who couldn't be restrained
well if we do anymore in America we
couldn't do it without adding that what
we're doing around the world is
providing care for anybody that shows up
that needs it including men who have sex
with women everywhere else everywhere we
work we try to treat whoever needs the
medicine to stay alive without
discrimination to do outreach to all the
populations that need it everywhere in
the world we work we have not been
particularly active here in the United
States and I will one reason I want to
have this meeting today is that I think
we all not all of us not the other
panelists but people like me who think
we know and care a lot about this they
got a little too casual about the
problem sneaking back up on us in
America and assuming dimensions that
we're not properly being managed so the
short answer your question is if I can
figure out some place we can make a
contribution consistent with our
obligations around the world which are
very large and includes selling
medicines in 70 countries and having
public health networks in more than 30
yes I would do that and in other
countries we do that right now and we
should everybody should can I just make
the point and abuse the moderators
privilege for a moment to say that the
mantra the slogan for World AIDS Day
this year is universal access which
meant full treatment prevention and care
by the end of 2010 which is obviously
not going to happen and human rights and
one of the phenomenal moves backward
that is presently occurring
internationally on human rights is what
is happening to men who have sex with
men in Uganda in the light of a new bill
a private member's bill that's been
introduced into the parliament without
the objection so far of the President or
of his cabinet so it is a proceeding
apace it's a bill which not only
prescribes life imprisonment for anyone
who's gay but it also demands of
everyone into society whether parent or
teacher or doctor or nurse or civil
society activists whomever if they
suspect or know a person
a woman child a boy or girl who may be
gay they are to report it to the
authorities within 24 hours and on top
of that any HIV positive gay man who has
sex with another gay person is subject
to the death penalty it's the most
hideous erosion of human rights and
speaks to the phenomenon that 77
countries in the world have sodomy
anti-gay laws and 40 of those 53
countries are in the Commonwealth and it
is in fact becoming a very serious issue
in the combat of AIDS in the
concentrated epidemic among men who have
sex with men I've been given the signal
for one final question can I ask each of
you quickly to to give a brief sense of
where we should now go if we were
speaking to young people in particular
what is what is the battleground how do
we how do we wage this fight hereafter
let's start with Kelly and we'll move
across quickly I think that for me
really simply just love access and
education we first have to teach people
that there is love out there there's
opportunity out there for them and that
those individuals that are being lost to
the system that are being lost our
educational systems that are being lost
to poverty that are being lost to
homelessness because they've come out in
their their homes and have been ejected
from their households and forced to face
life on their own like so many people
that I found sitting outside of the Ruth
Ellis drop-in center in Detroit Michigan
who were 13 and 14 and outside at four
o'clock in the morning without a roof
over their heads because they came out
to their parents we have to establish a
system of love in our country and adapt
zero tolerance for any type of abuse or
neglect to any children in this country
we have to provide comprehensive and
appropriate education to our children so
that they know how to compete and our
global account in our global economy
possible so they have life skills so
that they can take care of themselves in
this world and in this country and
lastly they have to have access to
health they have to have access to
quality and affordable education not
only on the prime
secondary secondary level but they also
have to have access to higher education
to be competitive in this world and
finally they have to have access to
health care with fifty percent of people
not having access to health care in this
country 21% who don't know that they're
infected and twenty-nine percent who
have HIV we just can't get access to the
medications that will keep them alive is
absolutely intolerable in this in this
country in the United States of America
and we have to do something about that
today thank you
and I agree fully and I also say on the
government side we have to invest in
prevention I think roughly the budget
now allows roughly about 4% for
prevention and when we invest in
prevention to make sure the resources
are going to those areas and communities
of greatest need so that we can do the
outreach we can provide the education we
can work with the women the girls men
who have sex with men and young gay men
now who are also increasing of the
numbers are increasing in terms of
infection so while we do the work on the
treatment the care the housing which is
necessary and we must continue and but
we must focus on what can we do on the
prevention side so we can begin to keep
the numbers down and the best way I know
working through many of the faith and
community based organizations and
partnering with health departments
throughout the country and working with
other groups who are focused on these
kind of issues outreach education
getting people educated getting people
tested we've got to do more in terms of
getting people tested here in New York
State we're continuing to work to try to
turn the public law around with respect
to routine testing we need to have
routine testing and not have barriers to
people are getting routine testing and
of course we have to look at something
we've not said much about today but I
think we have to give much more
attention and that is incarcerated
population as more people or being
released from prisons coming back into
the communities re-establishing
relationships across the board we must
be concerned and no congresswoman maxine
waters has some phenomenal legislation
to address this we need to get behind
legislation that will require testing
going in and test in coming out and
lastly I would say on behalf of the many
clergy members who are working on these
issues across the country that's a very
important piece of legislation HR 1964
the National Black hiv/aids Elimination
Act that is designed to address much of
what we are talking about here today the
disproportionate impact of hiv/aids
within the black community including
ms/ms must be addressed by people who
have the experience have the knowledge
and have invested in making this
legislation a reality it's comprehensive
is bold and it touches up on all of the
areas that we've been discussing today
so legislation is important thank you I
agree with the previous two speakers I
do think we know what works I mean we
know what works in prevention we know
what works in treatment and we need to
use our knowledge the evidence we have
and go out there and implement it where
it's needed and scale it up what the
president was saying we need to take it
to action and we can't wait we need to
take those little needle exchange works
we need to take it to action we need to
take it to scale working with
communities of em SMS and
african-american communities can work
and we need to take that to scale we
have interventions that we know work but
we haven't taken them to scale we
haven't implemented them and then
there's a very important other area that
we need to invest in that hasn't been
mentioned before in its research there
are lots of unanswered questions there
are lots of ways I mean we've made
enormous progress through research and
discovery in terms of how to tackle this
epidemic
how to prevent the horrific effects of
the epidemic on people but there needs
to be an continued investment in
research research into new ways of how
to prevent effective ways of preventing
transmission and then researching better
treatment for people living with HIV
research on how to do operations which
how to implement these programs how to
scale them up how to develop these
networks whether they be in New York and
Harlem or in Lesotho there's a lot of
room for inquiry and knowledge
generation that I need to continue we
need to continue to push on learning
more because I think through learning
more we'll be able to do more Thank You
mr. president well first I agree with
what's been said I particularly want to
emphasize the importance of listening to
people and discreet populations whether
it's men who have sex with men whether
it's women who have sex with the lovers
you just got out of prison with what I
think you have to listen to Twitter it's
kids that are in at-risk populations and
turn off all the messages because it
looked like they come from oh Claire
haired people like me and it's boring we
have to figure out a way to reach people
and I particularly think that we have
made a colossal oversight not doing more
with the imprisoned population in
general I mean in general ninety percent
of people in jail are getting out and
now of course there's all this
controversy over this terrible incident
of the shooting of the police officers
in Washington and whether that man's
sentences should have ever been commuted
in Arkansas and whether he could have
been held in washington i don't know
about the facts but but most people's
released from prison is automatic has
nothing to do with the intervention of a
clemency ninety percent of people we
were there are going to get out that and
we spent all this money to warehouse
them put them with people of the same
sex I think even now only Mississippi
unbelievably is the only state in the
country that allows conjugal
is for heterosexual couples I think they
still are and so and by and large that
education is limited there were scores
of great college education programs in
prison and almost zero recidivism rate
until nineteen ninety five when a
Republican congressman one of their
first acts after taking the majority was
to prohibit Pell Grant funds from being
used to defray the cost of a college
education so now they went from scores
down to about 11 four of which are in
new york i'm proud to say thanks to an
NGO here but we need to go back and go
back to square one on this prison
population and really try to
dramatically reduce either the number of
people who are infected while they're in
prison are their inclination out of
desperation spite or whatever to infect
others when they get out i think that's
important abroad I know I sound like a
broken record but I've just seen it too
many times you train a few community
health workers you have basic I mean
very basic refrigeration and lab
facilities build national networks and
we'll get the medicine out there and
we'll get the money for it out there and
we'll save the lives I will do what I
promised the gentleman over there to do
about the budget but in the meanwhile I
hope you'll hold your fire they still
got a few cards to play and the present
sent a terrible situation I do think we
will wind up doing more here and I think
it's imperative that we do we you can't
be satisfied with the fact that we
increased from three to four million and
treatment last year when there's still
more than five million who need it and
we just got to keep working on driving
the prices down driving the quality up
and getting the systems out there that's
what I believe in the rest of the world
in America it's more a set of discrete
challenges thank
let me on your collective behalf ask you
to exert one further round of
appreciation for our panel
and
and let let me in personal terms thank
vox populi for rescuing the conversation
i am going to i'm going to call on Dean
linda free to i think has some final
words to say i'm sorry there the the
panel discussion is complete direct your
attention to the Dean well good
afternoon and I want to end this really
fabulous discussion with several
comments first of course hiv/aids is a
public health problem but i think the
discussion that we just had among our
wonderful panelists exemplifies that the
solution sit with all of us and all of
us appreciating what a multi-sectoral
solution might be which is appreciating
the complexity of the problem and
solving it together with new knowledge i
want to thank very much both the whole
audience for being part of this and our
distinguished panel for leading our
thinking and as we take stock of where
we are in terms of hiv/aids both
globally and domestically i particularly
want to thank president Bollinger for
convening this along with dr. al-sadr
President Clinton for your critically
important leadership in tackling HIV and
other global health threats identifying
innovative solutions and in mobilizing
partnerships through your Clinton Global
Initiative and for your support and many
contributions to improving lives around
the world including the Clinton HIV aids
initiative which is helping as we all
know two million people living with
hiv/aids excess life-saving drugs I want
to thank Virginia fields for your
long-standing leadership in terms of HIV
programs and people living with HIV in
New York as well as to the res
solution of disparities broadly we are
deeply grateful I want to thank Stephen
Lewis for your incomparable commitment
to justice and you're relentless
advocacy which we saw a small glimpse of
today and deeply appreciate broadly and
for the empowerment of women and girls
around the world and to Kelly Lindsay
deep thanks for all of the work that you
do on domestic issues and policy and
hiv/aids and I want to acknowledge dr.
Wafaa al-sadr and the Melman School of
Public Health at Columbia University the
icap program the international center
for AIDS care and treatment programs
which has really brought a unique
approach to helping to solve the issues
and problems of hiv/aids worldwide their
unique approach includes working
hand-in-hand with ministries of Health
other governmental and non-governmental
organizations academia and persons with
HIV and affected communities emphasizing
the design of health systems that work
that create the ability with capacity
building and technical assistance to to
implement adorable response to
prevention and treatment of HIV and
other health threats in the communities
where it works and focusing on this
innovative family-centered approach as
the winning way to respond to the needs
of communities and strengthen the fabric
of societies and also as with everyone
on this panel to your dedicated
attention to both the US and the global
epidemic marrying knowledge and science
with service and training now I'd like
to attempt to summarize what I think we
have all heard today as our charge for
the future but I also recognize that the
panel is on a very tight time schedule
and so while I continued they may well
need to to leave but I think many of you
have been here for the whole day
attending a full day symposium entitled
HIV program scale-up and global health
systems sponsored by I cap and supported
by the Rockefeller Foundation at this
symposium what we have heard is a very
rich discussion of the impact of HIV on
health systems and the strategies for
health systems to serve people with HIV
and to serve their broader needs this I
think reflects and brings us very much
to today's panel and reflections are
where we are at this moment in time and
where we must go there clearly as a
number of the panelists said have been
many successes led by those of you in
the audience as well as those of you on
the stage but we cannot afford either
the complacency that has said in that
things are working sufficiently nor can
we afford to not attend to the fact that
only forty two percent of people who
need treatment are getting it or that
the rates of HIV infection are rising in
many subpopulations in our communities
and around the world there are
increasing needs for meds while budgets
are flatlined we need creative solutions
in systems that work and I honor the
panel for really trying to address the
complexity of those needs the problem is
complex the solutions are solutions that
work are not simple although they may
sometimes seem clear as in public health
as a whole public health is about all of
our health but it is all of our health
with an eye to ensuring the well-being
of the most vulnerable subsets of our
society and making sure that they
get the equitable prevention and care
not only that they deserve but that
signifies our commitment to creating a
world of equity that we want to live in
so I think the panel has done a fabulous
job today of bringing those issues
together I thank you deeply for the
charge you have given us to think about
how to move forward with a commitment at
many levels no one solution will be
sufficient but everyone is needed access
to Universal high quality care both
domestically and globally is necessary
absolutely necessary but will not be
sufficient we need the creation of
health systems as dr. al-sadr has said
so eloquently which addressed multiple
human needs in the same person and the
family and understand that one problem
such as HIV increases risk for other
diseases or other outcomes and that
people need to be treated holistically
and with their own needs broadly in mind
and we must move too much more
sophisticated investment in how we are
going to prevent HIV for the future as
well as treat it more effectively that's
going to require all of us working at
many levels and together thank you all
so much for a really momentous afternoon
thank you very much
I as we leave I just want to thank all
of you for coming and our former Mayor
David Dinkins thank you Thank You
Kenneth Cole for all the great work you
do damn farm and you should know that
one of the participants here and a great
philanthropist and world-class human
being here for the rock and roll hall of
fame concert is the great guitarist of
you to edge my great friend thank you
for coming thank you all have a great
time